welcome back to uncensored now over the
last few years images like this have
become somewhat familiar when we talk
about police officers across the world
in wealth in the UK met police chief of
Sir Mark Rowley wants to see an end to
it he's saying black lives matter Pride
those types of events a range of other
social and cultural issues from now on
his officers will be told not to take
the knee to not fly rainbow Flags or
wear badges that support environmental
causes so is this a return to good
old-fashioned policing as some are
suggesting or is it a backwards step to
a time when the police were seen as
enemies by some minorities and
marginalized communities here to discuss
all of this former police officer of 31
years and director of the Law and Order
Foundation Norman Brennan in Scotland
strategic advisor on a quality diversity
and inclusion for police Scotland and
former haringey police Commander Dr
Victor olisa and from Los Angeles we're
joined by former BLM activist Xavier de
Russo to talk about this International
nationally as well but I will begin with
Norman here in the studio Norman uh you
know you're a copper of the sort of
traditional order I think I can call you
that and you talk a lot about policing
now what do you make of this move to
basically dework the police force well I
fully support the Met commissioner smart
Rowley
um the long and the short is is that
when you join the Police Service you
join to police all communities you're
there for everyone and everyone there's
nobody that you favor in part on one
over another that's why all police
officers Mis act impartially and we're
told to police without fear or favor so
my main concern is that you should join
the Police Service wear your uniform
stand straight and strident kneel to
nobody Buckle to nobody and the only
time you kneel or Buckle is when you're
saving someone's life who's having a
heart attack or someone that has been
shot or stabbed and you're placing your
hands over to try and save their lives
apart from that where your uniform smart
the same uniform I don't want to see
police vehicles being painted all sorts
of colors and you certainly don't kneel
down to anybody and I think the few
offices that did kneel including one
Chief Constable will never be doing that
again I just want to pick up that point
you made about without fear or favor I
found that interesting because in
journalism use that phrase a lot being a
good journalist means doing so without
fear or favor but of course journalists
are biased it gets pointed out a lot
everyone has personal biases police
officers on the job they're professional
no doubt many of them are but they are
going to have inbuilt biases depending
on their upbringing and the way they
feel about certain topics so there have
been complaints throughout Decades of
ethnic minorities saying that they felt
that they weren't treated fairly by
police officers so do you think any kind
of social justice causes helps that
well to be quite honest of you you say
that many black people I deal with I I
don't look at their color yes they are
black when I grew up in Wembley I was
known as the white black man there was
in my rugby team there were 13 black
players and two white players so I grew
up with the community black community I
went to school with them and I policed
with them and I policed certain areas of
London that were black and you know what
I pleased without fear or favor a black
uh a black robber or a burglar early
hours of the morning stabbed me in the
chest when I tried to arrest him for
committing three armed burglaries he
didn't stab me because I was a white
policeman he stabbed me because he was
trying to get away I didn't arrest him
because he was black I arrested him
because he was a robber so I think
all this all this stuff that we keep in
hearing in the media that the police
pick on black people or gay people or
anybody else there may be a handful but
I promise you this you've probably got
one of the best but sadly the weakest uh
Police Service that we've ever had but
they're the most tolerant we've ever had
as well and I'm afraid tolerance
sometimes hasn't worked well in their
favor interesting stuff I want to bring
in Victor to this now he's been
listening in and Victor you're very
involved in diversity and inclusion in a
police force you're listening to those
comments from uh Norman now do you agree
no I don't agree uh there are far too
many things
that I don't agree with not what
normally just said and I'd like to start
before I go on I serve 35 years in the
Police Service
but also the rank of Chief
superintendent has served in some of the
most challenging places had a privilege
to serve as some of the most challenging
places in London and I'm proud to have
been a police officer
let me start off by Norman saying he
doesn't see colors I think you ought to
I think every single officer who polices
any public area should see color should
see difference should respect different
and what we start saying we don't see
color we don't see difference that's
where the problem starts now so Mark has
been very clear that the police as an
institution the Met as an organization
should not be linked to any causes but
not the same as an officer
who has his or her Authority Under the
crowns the Constable can't show empathy
cat show respect for people who may be
suffering or people who suffer or whose
Community have suffered
and Injustice that is very different
from actually having a political cause
and as a police officer one of the
things that you ought to have going on
the peeling principle that we're here is
to protect life first and foremost is to
be able to show empathy and I think it
is wrong to start quoting walk
um activities being walk about anything
and not being a public servant that
shows empathy and understanding and when
officers start doing that as individuals
as an organization we talk about the
good old days of the cop going back to
policing and and solving crime police
have never been particularly effective
in solving crimes without the public and
if we start saying that some of the
areas in which police face the greatest
challenges are those areas where people
with from different protected
characteristic lives if we can't make we
as an organization can't make contact
relationship build trust with them then
we're not going to get or the police are
not going to get the information that
they need to solve crime to be effective
to be efficient and to earn the trust of
all communities Victor thank you Norman
I'll give you a chance to respond
shortly but want to bring Xavier in on
this listening in from across the pond
the Atlantic and the black lives matter
movement of course that started that
police taking the knee and many other
people as well what do you make of the
decision then to try and stop this
activity within police forces have you
I think it's a great decision police the
officers need to get back to basics stop
worrying about being woke and start
worrying about being strong because I've
been black for 26 years and I have great
relationships with a lot of Law
Enforcement Officers that's because they
don't view me as a skin color they view
me as a law-abiding citizen because
that's what I am and look I live in Los
Angeles California I don't even wear my
glasses in public anymore because I have
seen enough there is so much crime
across our nation because we have a
shortage of quality police officers to
protect our communities the reason we
have such a shortage is one to defund
the police movement and more more
significantly police officers are
treated like crap both by the public but
especially by their department heads and
that's only going to worsen if police
officers keep being inserted into
Political discussions So to avoid that
we need to police officers to be just
like most Professionals in the world and
hold the political views until they are
off the clock it's not a police
officer's job to enforce their opinions
it's a police officer's job to enforce
the law Norman there you go Xavier
agreeing with a lot there but Victor
also calling you out for not seeing
color
well Victor is doing exactly what we're
all concerned about he's saying that we
should look at black people and look at
them differently I'm telling you know we
shouldn't I'm saying that we should
stand up and we should police all
communities without fear or favor and
one of the biggest criticisms against
the police nowadays and I was a police
officer for 31 years on a robbery scored
for six years is that the number of
black uh suspects or black people young
men particularly that are stopped in
search well when 73 74 of all Street
robberies murders and stabbings are
committed by young black men often on
other black men who is it that the
police are meant to be stopping 50 white
people to satisfy the black community
and 50 of the black community to satisfy
the politicians and the woke Brigade or
if seven crimes out of every ten of
knife crime homicide gun crime is
committed by young black men it's they
that we should be targeting and how
anybody can say that is racist it's
beyond me unless of course you stop
someone and the connotations of your
words or conduct are racist we have to
give a final word to Victor on that
Victor unfortunately a short of time but
give you an opportunity to respond no of
course Norman is talking about a small
part of London there are people who
commit knife crimes in other parts of
England they're not black
okay they're not 70 people who commit
offenses commit offenses because they
are committing offenses not because of
their color not because of the
nationality not because of protective
characteristics you should police
regardless and if you don't see color
you don't see difference you don't see
empathy you don't take into account that
black people as you just said Norman you
look at the stop and search data they're
disproportionately stopped and searched
wherever you go in the UK that saying as
an institution of policing black people
are criminogenic that is absolutely
wrong you need to see difference to
actually police difference I'm not
saying you should Mark out people given
privileged treatment but you should
understand that by seeing difference
then you stop stereotyping you stop
acts in a way that disadvantages them
that's policing without fear or favor
whether you're black white or male or
female the long and the short is the
majority of police officers do not get
do not get the support that they deserve
because the majority of honest
hard-working caring non-violent
non-racist but unfortunately the
narrative tells everyone difference I'm
here to speak up for the front line tens
of thousands of honest men and women
that are called racist after or
misogynistics
majority of police officers are not car
races the majority of police officers do
a good job there's a handful of police
officers who behave badly let's talk
about those officers dealing with those
officers lest or categorize
1998 99 of police officers men and women
who do fantastic jobs who see color who
see difference who show empathy who are
the best of public servants will agree
on agree on that point let's end on that
agreement unfortunately straight out of
time but we do want to get all three of
you back to continue this conversation
it's been really interesting thanks all
three